boys and girls this is miscarry I feel
like since becoming a mom you know you
kind of have different emotional strings
that things can can pull on anything
having to do with kids I will get you
know choked up about I just love
listening to them
no crying ugly here after seeing a
Facebook post featuring these third and
fourth graders performing her song the
champion Kari was so moved she decided
to crash their rehearsal there we
perform
[Applause]
can't wait for you guys to crush it on
Sunday you guys are gonna be so amazing
that crowd is gonna not know it hit on
them the kids perform for the crowd at
CMA fest proceeds from the event go
directly just supporting music education
for kids with artists donating their
performances Kerry was there sharing the
stage with a legend
it was kinda like what if Jim Jack came
to the CMA fest and well let's Oscar and
so she agreed and I'm just so excited
for for the fans and for heard and since
2006 the CMA Foundation has invested
nearly 12 million dollars to support
Nashville public school students which
is so amazing
[Music]